I'm moving on so again and Jeremy TR I
want people to be entrepreneurs because
they think they've got something of
value to give to the world not because
they can think a lot of money again this
is where it's going to be really
important provide the value not just go
after the money one more from Dave
Thomas founder of Wendy's when you give
more you get in return and it's true you
know keep giving keep giving to your
clients and they're going to keep coming
back ordering more telling more friends
and referred clients will buy more asked
last questions will be more loyal
they'll tell more people and it's a
great way to build your business without
having to spend a lot of money on
unofficial formal marketing and the last
rule of our six is two model success and
this is one of my favorite tips and I
think it's an awesome way for
entrepreneurs to shortcut their path to
success is if you want to achieve
anything with your business even with
your life the best way that I found is
look at somebody who's already doing it
and try to learn from their success they
can help show you the way and when I
would have my first software company I
was 19 years old didn't know anything
about how to build the business and was
a little scared and thought you know
what I'm not the first got to try to
sell software before so we research
companies like Microsoft and McAfee into
it and looked at how do they get started
I don't care how Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars now but how do you
go from that idea that making this first
million dollars that's what I want to
learn this is what I want to be able to
copy and we copied those success
strategies and put them to place in our
software business and we were to explode
our growth and get customers into 30
countries and get some branding
customers and eventually get acquired
and we sold our business and so it's in
it's an amazing way and this is what we
try to share with our ongoing posts of
the famous entrepreneur and it doesn't
have to be somebody you know for me
wasn't people that that I personally
knew but I still considered somebody
like Bill Gates to be my mentor because
I was able to learn a lot from his
success so when you're looking at
mentors you can look at people who you
do know who are or who are actual people
who can get some contact with but also
what I call aspirational mentor
where people who you look up to who
never even need to meet them to be able
to learn from their success and copy it
and put it into your own business as
well so a quick quote from kiyosaki your
mentors in life are important to choose
them wisely I couldn't agree more and I
think when you're looking at mentors
again you want to find the aspirational
ones people you look up to but don't
know but then also try to connect with
real people so people who are in your
city you may not know them but you want
to reach out to them and learn from
their success so this is something that
I promise you guys right at the
beginning the sample mentoring script
and this is something that I would use
if I wanted to get to know somebody who
was you know close to me that i can go
pay a visit to but i didn't know them
and something and somebody i've
researched and it was excited to meet
but i did not you know them so no dear
mr. mrs. whoever my name is your name
and i've always wanted to become an
internet marketer I've always want to
become a carpenter retail store whatever
it is I finally taking the steps to get
started kept coming across your name
everywhere research I have a great
respect what you do and would love to
pick your brain and ask you a few
questions it took me a while to muster
up the courage to write to you and I
hope you'll consider it even it's just
talking to you while you're walking to
an appointment or to your car named time
in the place and I'll be there with
concrete in hand thank you so much to
the opportunity of no idea how much this
means to me there's anything you can
think of it I can do for you as well
please let me know sincerely your name
this is really hard to say no to it's
important when you're trying to get in
on the mentoring relationship that you
don't go in starting asking will you be
my mentor right if they've never heard
of you I mentoring relationship is an
ongoing time-consuming thing so I get
emails really be my mentor it's hard for
you say yes I will be your mentors I
don't know anything about you so when
you're approaching people you want to
make it really easy for them to say yes
make it just a tiny little tiny time
commitment on their parts they're not
really investing too much and then you
could take it from there right this is a
letter that's hard to say no to but
probably say yes to a coffee or quick
phone call and if they see your passion
in your enthusiasm and they like you you
and with something like if I have any
other questions would you mind if I sent
you an email or called you and almost
always they'll say yes people want to
help people if you look at any
successful entrepreneur you'll see that
they had people who helped them get to
where they are and so they like being
able to give back but the only one to do
it to somebody who they think will
actually take their advice and use it
this is such a great feeling when you
when you help somebody and you see that
they took what you said and put it the
practice and had success but it's a bad
feeling when you go to somebody and you
give them advice and they don't do
anything you know that's not a sign of
great feeling you feel like you wasted
your time and so that's the risk for a
lot of mentors they don't want to waste
your time but they do want to help
people who are genuinely interested in
becoming a success and popping what
they've done so i will try to find
people local who you admire we want to
learn from and offer take them out the
coffee and use use the sample script as
we're to get you started if you do use
it you have success email me because I
want to hear about it and then some
simple questions you want to think about
what you're going to ask me do find you
get that meeting and why did you start
business how did you first customer
what's it will day in your life like
these just some examples you can
obviously add more specific ones to to
your business what you love most about
your business what you hate most big
mistake you ever made you have any
advice for some of me just starting up
so these are general ones that can apply
to any business regardless of you know
what what industry you're in and then I
always try to add something at the end
about is there absolutely anything that
I can help you with and for the most
part they may say no but they could be
flattered that you asked right you may
not be able to help your mentor her your
mentee out too much but you still want
to offer a quick example from my own
story when I was getting started I I was
mentored by an older gentleman and he
was not very technology savvy he didn't
really know anything about technology he
used no fax machines and didn't have an
email account and so he gave me a lot of
great advice and what I did was I just
had a quick simple google news alerts
for his company name and for his
industry and i kept getting ongoing
research of what
people were saying about him and I would
fax that to him and he was really
appreciative that somebody took the time
to keeping with the day was what was
what was being said so if you have an
advantage that you can use somehow and
usually there is a big age gap between a
mentee and mentor so there may be
something that you can use their to be
able to benefit them even if they can't
think of what you can do you always want
to look at different ways to do it now
if they are on quick quick pack if they
are on social media one of the things
that I've done is I'll have my assistant
goal and I know I'm meeting somebody
will have them check out their Twitter
account facebook page and youtube
channel if they have it and I try to
find something that they're interested
in so they say they really like the
coffee shop the local coffee shop then
before I meet them I'll pick up some
treats when local coffee shop it's just
a great way to start off the
relationship that's a bonus if they are
on Twitter and they do talk about that
kind of stuff so those are some sample
questions again you can come up with
your own but it's a great starting point
you want to keep it short and hopefully
if you see that you're you have the
genuine enthusiasm and desire to learn
more about the business then they'll be
happy to answer those questions and also
give you further you know help as you go
on so they may not be a mentor you know
formal mental relationship right in the
beginning and that something is really
hard to ask so make it simple stupid
easy for them so that they can say yes
and you start off the relationship so
that was my my big speech hopefully you
guys enjoyed it and I'm ready to answer
some questions if you guys have them